ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by host of the North Star podcast
and all-around interesting Internet
person David Parral David welcome to the
show thank you I'm really excited to be
here we've had some technical problems
but we've managed to girdle them around
and we fixed it and we're fully working
now right we're resilient my friend no
matter where we are no matter what's in
our way yeah so we haven't got an agenda
for today we're just going to talk about
whatever is being going on so what have
you had on your mind recently David yeah
so well spent the last 10 days in
Morocco so that has absolutely been the
thing most on my mind and I mean that
was that was wonderful it's really the
first time in recent memory that I've
spent 10 - I've barely consumed any
information just pure observation and
pure just living and really enjoyable
had actually forgotten what it was like
to just be in a state of pure
observation and the ways in which your
whole brain chemistry changes the ways
in which you experience the world
differently the ways in which time
begins to dilute and kind of expand but
then also now that I'm back thinking
through the benefits and the virtues of
routine and it's just something been
thinking a lot about but Morocco is an
amazing country in terms of my takeaways
from the trip I think that tourism there
is about to explode there's three main
reasons why I think Africa is
fascinating in terms of what it means
for the future of the world and
geographically Morocco is in a really
interesting place it's on the
northwestern tip of Africa and it's 9
miles across the Strait of Gibraltar to
get to Spain so Morocco the countries
that have the most tourism visits to the
country are France Germany and Spain
yeah and so in the northern northern
part of the country you'll hear a lot of
French and a bit of Spanish and then
there's Arabic spoken everywhere and so
so close what the Moroccan government is
doing and they own a hundred percent of
the airline which is called Royal Air
Maroc they're gonna position Morocco is
a kind of gateway to Africa meaning
that'll be the first place you go and
then you can sort of spread into it and
if you look at I'm an airline buff so if
you look at singapore qatar united arab
emirates iceland all those countries
they own a hundred percent of their
national airline and they've used that
national airline to increase business in
the country increase tourism and morocco
is about to do exactly that then the
government has what's called the vision
2020 initiative and they want to make
tourism the biggest industry in the
entire country so right now it's
agriculture and man i'll tell you we're
walking through the northern part of the
country so we're about an hour and a
half south of the mediterranean sea and
we were going on a hike so we're in just
a very very very rural area super poor
and there at these women we saw five
women and it was like a Frida Kahlo
painting these women had probably twenty
thirty pounds probably more of of leaves
on their back just walking through the
mountains we saw donkeys and mules you
know helping these farmers tend their
fields and it went to show that right
now agriculture is the number one
biggest industry in the country and
that's sort of the problem agriculture
in the ways in which they do it doesn't
scale like a lot of more industrial
first world country you know Barack was
pretty developed but it's very different
from an American agriculture I grew up
in California it's very different from
what you see in many parts of the
Central Valley and so what they want to
do is they want to really have tourism
explode which gets to my third point
that it Morocco's like the most
Instagram about country in the world
this will be a great segue into some of
the ways in which I think about the
world but like the world is look it's
not becoming more visual I think people
use that but it's a bit lazy because if
reading is was the dominant way in which
knowledge was transferred from
after the Gutenberg Revolution until
basically now reading is inherently
visual what I like to say is that it's
becoming more imagistic and the world is
being run by images and the dominant
place where a lot of that is happening
right now it's Instagram and when you go
to Marrakesh which is the number one
tourism city in Morocco the patterns we
were laughing actually look better on
your phone in the person cuz all the
blemishes kind of go away and we were
joking that like there were these you
know 19th to early 20th century kings
who were having all their workers design
these beautiful palaces just exquisite
classic Morocco and we were joking that
they knew that Instagram was gonna
happen like 200 years before before we
did they get in the architects in and
they're thinking that's a four hundred
like photo there that's like a five four
or five hundred like photo oh these are
straight eight hundred like there will
be people at home booking flights just
so that they can get straight on the
upregulate they're their Instagram
algorithm I hope so I'm an ambassador I
got it
um one of the things you touched on at
the start there was about what happens
when you take time away and you come
back
I think the marrying of enough space to
reconnect with just the world and to
take things in and beyond receive but at
a much slower pace at a pedestrian pace
as opposed to at a motorway speed which
I think we are often when we're
interconnected with the Internet and
then coming back to realize oh well
actually I also love my routine I wonder
whether I certainly feel this way like
the grass is always greener no matter
which side of it I'm on like sometimes
when I'm away I'm like I felt like I've
missed my routine and then as soon as
I'm back I'm like oh well I do love my
routine but I missed the fact that I was
immersed in this culture I recently went
to Rome and got to walk through the
Vatican and the Sistine Chapel and the
Colosseum and Pompeii and I'm just like
overloaded with visual stimulus right
like more than any that I could have
scrolled on Instagram for a day and I
would have got less but it just feels
like it's delivered a more pedestrian
pace a pace that my brain is built to
deal away
and I don't get home and feel like I'm
burned out I feel like I'm energized
whereas you know if you've done a long
flight and you've maybe not got yourself
off your phone oh you've been doing
whatever I feel the dopamine hangovers a
lot more obvious yeah yeah I think I
phrased it a little bit differently I
don't really have a pause button so I
just go ham every day and I just like
rush like mad and so I'm pretty intense
with both so I wouldn't even consider it
a pause button what I think a lot of is
I think of a lot of life like a rubber
band and if you look at what a rubber
band is is it's like tension and release
it's actually like great music right
like great electronic music which is
what I generally listen to is a series
of adding layers and layers to music
creating a kind of tension releasing
that tension and then flipping to a new
form of tension and then releasing that
and when you go to these shows what you
see is they do that not only with the
music but with color and with different
visuals so you're getting a kind of
similar tension and release but then the
way in which that's manifesting itself
is changing throughout the show and so I
think music is an amazing metaphor for
life part of the reason I listen to it
so much but it's I also draw amazing
inspiration from music and so to get
back to your question when I think of
the role of travel when I think of the
role of observation the role of
conversation all of these things are
extremely important but I see them more
as a kind of like tension in the rubber
band where when I'm in routine mode I'm
in straight production mode and I'm
capitalizing on on the tension that I
have created where is what travel and
pure observation is and then I would
bucket conversation and different
experiences is that as adding tension
and it's like breathing right it's like
you can't breathe out all the time but
you also can't inhale all the time and
it's like through that process of
breathing and not breathing
you're not pausing breathing it's just
more of a
kind of rhythm and a cadence and for me
travel is adding tension and then when I
get back I want to have added so much
tension that I can be in full production
mode yeah if I as you straight back into
your routine yeah exactly but there's no
pause for me I mean I'm a bit of a nut
but there's no pause and that's that's
an important distinction to make yeah I
guess so one thing dates I wanted to get
onto was a recent article that you have
written about writing for the internet
is that right yeah
yeah yeah that's exactly right so I mean
one of the ways in which I see the world
is I'm always looking for arbitrage
opportunities so generally I think that
if you look at economic history there is
the efficient markets hypothesis and
that whole idea is basically that when
you have many different people
participating in a market for the most
part you'll get the wisdom of crowds
that will kick in and they will value an
asset fairly and I think a lot of life
looks like that you know there's like an
old joke with an economist who is
walking and sees a $29.95 better than
any college class I ever took and it's
not even close I was like falling asleep
at college class and this was right when
the internet was was coming up and a lot
of these things were coming up and I
remember the last few years of college I
had no desire to go to class because
what I could find online was simply more
injured
thing and those trends have really kept
going and so what you have is the supply
of really high quality information is
growing way slower than the demand for
it and so what you see time and time
again is people follow the same
three-step strategy to absolutely
transform and revolutionize their
careers and with this three-step
strategy what's amazing about it is it
means that you don't have to pay your
dues anymore
and so my goal this year is to help a
thousand people start writing eventually
I want to do ten thousand a hundred
thousand because I believe so strongly
in how writing can change your life and
so what this three-step process is to
have it be really simple is you pick an
area pick an industry that is small but
it's a merchant and you start learning
about it you learn as much as you can
and then you share what you learned pick
an industry learn as much as you can
share what you learn and if you pick the
right industry if you pick the right
area and that area grows you will be an
expert in that domain and you will have
what I call a personal monopoly on that
area and so I have launched a writing
course which really isn't about writing
it's about audience building it's about
connecting with people it's about
getting smarter by sharing your ideas
it's about creating jobs and
opportunities for yourself speaking gigs
consulting gigs finding mentors all that
sort of stuff and it's about using
writing as the new resume because
resumes are an outdated way to
communicate your talents and if you can
write and if you can communicate your
ideas and if you can share your unique
perspective on the world in a way that's
both engaging and entertaining you have
a massive massive advantage in this
world and so I've developed a whole
methodology for doing that and it's an
online course called rite-of-passage
amazing first off the but what why do
you think writing is an area in which
you see easily exploitable gaps as
opposed to moving to video so
opposed to podcasting or audio platforms
or any other way of being creative the
creative outlet totally so writing is
the most fundamental method of
communication so it is the pillar of any
successful career and the foundation of
basically any other form of media and
then also writing is hard so the way in
which I see it as the foundation is like
say that you're doing a speech right so
you're gonna go stand up in front of 500
people tomorrow afternoon and you have
two different ways of preparing the
first one is you just practice and you
speak to different friends and whatnot
and the second one is you actually write
it out you structure your arguments and
then you say this is what I'm gonna talk
about this is how I'm gonna structure my
ideas what writing allows you to do is
to think and then once you begin to
rewrite that is rethinking so writing
allows you to grapple with and explore
ideas from more perspectives and more
sides better than any other medium one
thing to go back to are the beginning of
our conversation that you find when
you're in pure observational mode is
you're always kind of on this topical
layer and conversation can help you dive
down a little bit deeper but if you
really want to explore the nooks and
crannies of an idea to see it like a
kaleidoscope from all different
perspectives writing is the best way to
do that now look I have a podcast I did
television in college I've done I've
published more than 100 YouTube videos I
am basically content agnostic but
writing is the way in which that I have
become smarter the thing that has given
me the most credibility because once you
write about something that is like a
proof of work it's a proof of work and
of an idea and so you know I'll ask you
like if you meet somebody who has a
podcast on a topic versus has written a
book on a topic you're probably gonna
trust the person who's written the book
about it because we have this intuitive
understanding that writing is rigorous
in a way that no other form of media is
and when
you write about your industry because of
the rigor of writing and the way in
which we've positioned the written word
in society writing has characteristics
that no other medium of communication
has and like I said at the beginning
writing is the single most fundamental
form of communication
it's definitely held in very high esteem
I think it's even the guys that I know
that are super good on Twitter and like
Twitter used to be maybe three four
years ago it was just a swamp right of
gifs and just it was terrible and now
you look on there and you've got these
life-changing Maxim's from guys like
James Kelly at James clears Twitter is
unbelievable like that guy that guy is
able to just constantly on a conveyor
belt put out whatever is three hundred
character limit Maxim's for life Navarre
rava can't like you know any anyone from
that sphere of people are able to write
and you are right there is something
very that makes you hold it in high
regard the fact that they can articulate
the written word not just a spoken word
I do think there's a place for both but
to comment on how current culture sees
the podcasting sphere I saw a meme the
other day that was about four white guys
when they smoke a joint and it just says
below it
dude we should totally start a podcast
and it's like it does feel like that
space now especially with how quick of
an emerging market the audio platform is
is almost becoming to matter for itself
like it's becoming it's becoming its own
pie like a caricature of its own
platform almost yeah maybe look I'm just
I think podcasts are incredible my point
is really just that in terms of the
podcasts that I create sure that I have
more than 10,000 listeners and that's
all great and people respond and they
say nice things but Wow when someone has
read something I've written the
relationship that I formed with them is
so deep and look
it's still true for podcasts I actually
think audio is amazing at inspiring
trust you're basically like a God in
somebody's head you've like seeped into
their ears and you wear these air pods
and you forget they're even wearing
headphones and there's like some
brilliant guy or girl like speaking in
your ear and she's saying things that
you've never thought before while you're
forgetting that you're even listening to
a podcast I mean it's incredible right
it's yeah look it's unbelievable but to
go back to the original point the way in
which writing helps you hone and develop
your thinking I mean take a guy like
James clear I had the privilege of
spending a morning with him a couple
months ago and we had an awesome
conversation and as I was preparing for
that interview I saw that for three
years in a row he was writing to
articles week that's a hundred 14
articles a year and then if you read
that book the way in which he could
distill his ideas and atomic habits the
way in which he could craft sentences
that really compress all the wisdom
writing is able to do that in a way that
no other media is because it's malleable
and you can play with it you can
distribute it you can get feedback with
it it's visual I mean it's so funny when
I was trying to edit my podcast when I
first started it dealing with audio is
just an absolute pain I mean you have
this like wave forms I mean it's really
like if you were to torture somebody you
would say at least for me you would say
hey go edit ten hours of audio and you
can't do a transcript with it yeah and
my goodness it's it's hard and it's
inefficient but when you look at writing
it allows you to sort of rewrite and
rethink which makes it a really valuable
medium that's something that's that's
super interesting the fact that you
you're not temporarily constrained when
you have the written word even when you
do drawing or if you do painting you can
maybe rub out little bits but after a
while you can only rub out so much
you can arrays small amounts but that's
not unless you're doing it on a graphics
tablet you actually can't continue to go
back over or else who's gonna wreck the
page you can erect a piece of paper like
this physical limits on how much pain
you can remove and also when you're
talking about video and audio once
you've done it and created it the only
way that you can make it better is to go
back and redo a game from either the
beginning of the sentence or the
beginning of the entire thing to go
through so yeah the fact that it's
malleable is a really interesting point
I think certainly for me writing is it's
a big challenge I think one of the
reasons there's probably a little bit of
confirmation bias one of the reasons why
I hold audio in such high esteem as it
comes easily to me and I know that for
me to become even close to as proficient
as I am audio writing would it's not
low-hanging fruit like it it's whatever
the opposite is it's like at the top of
the tree and whoa ok here's the thing
what you're saying is is is one of the
tragedy the trap the tragedies that I
hope to fix and look this isn't just a
writing course this is really a
community and online communication
course it just so happens that writing
right now is the single highest point of
leverage if that wasn't the case I
wouldn't be promoting writing at all I
have no attachment to the actual written
word and to be honest with you I don't
even consider myself a writer I consider
myself a communicator yeah I think of
myself as somebody who's interested in
ideas I think of myself who wants to
build an audience online and right now
writing is the best place to do that 10
years from now that might not be the
case yeah but to get back to your point
you know I was thinking about how you
were talking about painting typewriters
were a bit like that but now with
digital you can you can sort of rework
everything but the big thing that we try
to do in the course is flip all of
writing education on the 10 so if you
look at the structure of writing
education any system the ways in which
it works will flow from its end state so
in
writing what are the essays that you're
doing in school you're analyzing some
Shakespeare play that you never
understood thou shalt not do whatever
and you're doing these essays that are
almost all focused on literature and the
problem is that's not the kind of
writing that you need to build an
audience online and it's not the kind of
writing that you need to do well in
business and so my point is the way in
which that there there's really two
kinds of writing there's there's writing
for school which is driven by the PhDs
who go get a PhD in English and they
influence the entire system of writing
education Paul Graham has a great essay
on this and then there's another kind of
writing which is the writing I'm really
focused on which is not writing to be
like Thoreau or to be like any famous
author it's writing to get ideas out of
your head put them on a page and then
influence other people or share an
interesting idea with other people
because I'll tell you if you look at
history the people who have been able to
communicate the best have also been the
very people who have been able to
achieve things that they've wanted to
achieve and writing to get back to what
I was saying about being the most
fundamental form of communication
whether you're gonna do your own
podcasts whether they're gonna do your
own video series you know I like
watching a video series called every
frame of painting there's nerdwriter
both of them are incredible there's
Wendover they all have written scripts
so they start with writing before they
go into video and my point is that it's
not about writing to be a writer it's
about writing to share your ideas with
other people and distribute them and to
build an audience which is one of the
most valuable skills in the world right
now I mean the returns to to writing are
actually increasing they're exploding
and so this isn't really a writing
course it's a communication course
through writing interesting why do you
say that the returns to writing a on an
upward trend at the moment I mean look
at the people who we've spoken about so
far you found me through my writing we
spoke about navall rava Conte
he's a vociferous writer James clear is
a writer
you interviewed Rory Sutherland I
listened to that podcast episode it was
hilarious a full 7a German right it's a
force of nature he's the absolute ban
and I got an advance copy of his new
book and liked it first of all it's
phenomenal it it will do very well it's
like Freakonomics for behavioral finance
what you see though is if you take a guy
like rory sutherland he's an amazing
speaker right but he has honed and he's
crafted his jokes through writing he
writes for The Spectator and that is
where he works on a lot of his really
interesting ideas and when he has a
great anecdote like we had wheels on
luggage before we sent people to the
moon I read that that very idea in The
Spectator before I heard it on your
podcast yeah and that's just a perfect
example of how things can begin with
writing and you can hone and craft our
message I mean this is what comedians do
right what comedians do is so I live in
New York and one of the things that we
do for fun as we go to different comedy
shows and the thing that you get in
comedy that you get nowhere else is you
never know who's gonna be in front of
you so if you go to a concert you're
like oh my goodness
Odessa or Green Day or Muse will be
playing I know that if you go to a movie
you pick a movie you buy tickets for
that movie with comedy you're like I'm
gonna go to the Comedy Cellar at 8:00
p.m. on Friday and I have no idea who's
gonna be there [ __ ] Chris Rock might
show up Louie CK might show up and
what's going on this is what's happening
they have a big show that's coming up
and what comedians famously do is
they're always testing and refining
their jokes through live performance
yeah and they go out there watching the
reactions on people's faces and and I
remember a couple years
ago I was working a company called
'cycle and we did a documentary on this
it was a short five minute documentary
and it was about this guy who went to
four different comedy shows in a night
and showed how he changed that joke and
then we would get in the car we were in
the berm we would interview him and we
said what did you learn from that and
what happened was through the process of
sharing and then getting feedback
he was always refining his ideas and
that is why I encourage people to share
so much because when you start sharing
you're always getting feedback getting
feedback getting feedback and through
that you can refine your ideas and get
the framing right and stuff like that
and so to go back to Rory Sutherland
part of the reason I mean the guy is
just really intend to go back to
somebody who really does a good job
observing the world I don't think you
can find a better case study than Rory
Sutherland but what he has done is
through writing and through feedback
he has refined his jokes and now he has
a couple stories that when people hear
him for the first time they just yeah
his repertoire is is huge I think even
to take it to a more basic level than
that something that I've been talking
about a fair bit recently is many people
don't have any creative output or any
any pathway where they are forced to
articulate the things that are inside of
their head like even if you take it away
from writing for an essay very few
people actually engage in a deep
conversation where they're not
distracted by their phone and they're
not fragmented by other things going on
it's very often I think that people
don't even have to think beyond the
surface the near level of what their
thoughts are to then actually articulate
them the deeper thoughts that they have
about issues that are going on at the
moment or emotions they've had or
experiences that they've had I think
based on my experience often just stay
inside that person's head unless you
have a creative outlet like yourself or
me or you're a writer or a painter or an
artist or a musician at what point is a
lay person now actually being pushed to
articulate that
thoughts in a really sort of true and
deep way and I think that what that's
forcing are causing a lot of people to
do is actually become detached from not
only the ability to articulate but also
the ability to think if you've read 1984
we know that a restriction in language
is essentially the same as a restriction
in thinking because without the capacity
to articulate the thought you
essentially can't have the thought
itself or the thought only exists in
isolation and it's this cloudy nebulous
difficult to define like haze that's
just it's an ocean right you don't you
no longer have thought you just have
sentiments and notions and yeah you know
before even talking about writing
writing for a purpose or writing for a
site or to build up a readership or to
even get feedback simply the process of
being unsend and trying to articulate
your thoughts I think can be so
therapeutic and affected for a lot of
people oh absolutely and there's a guy
named John O'Donoghue and he asks he's
an Irish poet and he is magnificent it
was like this has been I've now read all
four of his books I had never heard of
him at the beginning of this year and in
a hundred days I just poured through
them and he's a Catholic priest Catholic
minister and then later in his career
focused a bit more on poetry and he
tragically died I think it is sleep at
something like the age of 54 but just is
it just one of those mines that you hear
him speak and he says things that you
should have known you should have
recognized but you could never really
put it into words and he asks in his
podcast with Krista Tippett on on on on
being he asked when was the last time
that you had a great conversation and to
echo your point he was saying that most
conversations are just two intersecting
monologues so one person says something
to somebody else another person says
something back
and there's this weird kind of
competition where both people are maybe
trying to one-up each other but every
now and then you'll have a conversation
that it's not a game of ping-pong
there's no there's no competition but
it's a conversation where you're
elevating onto a new plane of experience
and what's happening is as a human being
yourself you're saying things and
finding ideas within you that you didn't
even know existed parts of your soul
that you had forgotten about but the
other person is doing the same thing and
all of a sudden you're moving into this
new frontier onto this new plane of
experience and what he says is that
conversations like that sing afterwards
in your mind for weeks and that they're
like food and drink for the soul and
that's probably the most powerful idea
I've heard this year having good
conversation conversations where you are
elevating on to another realm of human
experience are I honestly I think that
that's what we live for and to get back
to writing writing is trying to do that
at scale yeah I think that the this son
being greater than the whole of the
parts during good conversations is
something that I've felt a much high
velocity than I've been used to since
starting this podcast just over a year
ago
and that kind of pharmaceutical grade
dose of a exposure to it has been very
enjoyable and I'm gonna continue to
strike this iron until all of the
listeners who are who are tuned in I
appreciate that they need to put their
phone down in the car and just ask ask
someone a question about something that
they care about I got so my messages
have come down from the top I know
you're gonna speak to a friend of the
show
George McGill I think at some point this
week from social chain in Manchester and
he's sent me a question asking you to
explain your thoughts about people who
consume the vast majority of their
content that's only been created within
the last 24 hours
he's a big mental models
we've done an episode which will be
already out now in podcast land and all
of the listeners should know what the
Lindy effect is but he's this has come
down I should have turned my
notifications off but for the first time
ever I'm glad that I didn't because
that's just pop down from the top of the
screen so this is as fresh as fresh of a
question is you're gonna get off the
press well it's funny cuz we're talking
about comedy right and so I was with
this must have been six months ago I was
with some friends and one thing that I
do is I hang out with all people in all
these different scenes New York happens
to be a hub for so many different
industries and I try to be surround
myself with people from let's see had
lots of people in crypto lots of people
in finance lots of creative people
different artists some in fashion but
then this was really with the influencer
community some youtubers and
instagramers who I had actually met
through Twitter and we were leaving my
friend's house and of course it was
Friday night we're driving up to a
comedy show and we get in the uber SUV
it was like one of the big ones and my
friend had ordered and I go in right
first you know like to those back seats
are like crawling and just worming
you're like doing gymnastics to get back
there right so I'm I go back I do like a
360 backflip to get in the back seat of
the car and I sit there and I'm looking
at what all the people in front of me
are doing on their phone and the ride
was 20-25 minutes not so long but what
was stunning to me just stunning was as
I watched the people in front of me tap
and text with like this kind of
ferocious intensity I saw that none of
them had consumed anything that had been
created outside of the last 24 hours
so they were all within snapchat stories
Instagram stories text message whatsapp
threads whatever but it was all new
content and I had this idea and actually
this encapsulate smiting probably better
than anything else and it will show you
how for me I write
a lot but I'm not a writer at all
writing for me is sort of the end state
of this way of life that I think is
extremely vibrant and writing is the way
in which kind of this end state in which
I capture my thoughts and experiences so
I had called this idea the perpetual now
and the idea was that the structure of
our social media feeds kinds of kind of
keeps us within this dis perpetual now
every time you open Facebook or Twitter
it's always new new new new new whatever
platform is and then I go to
unfortunately my grandfather passed
about two years ago and I was looking
through his library and in there I saw
more books from before at the 18th
century than from the 19th and 20th
centuries these books were covered in
highlights you saw Shakespeare here
different poets over there and what I
saw was this big shift from look this
isn't what everybody's doing but this is
the way in which our social media feeds
are structured keep us in this
ever-present now where what happens is
we become blind to our place in history
we become like overwhelmed by the
present and then when something happens
we just sort of get knocked off our feet
and I worry that if we're not conscious
of the structure of our social media
feeds we're going to drown in what I
then called the never ending now I had
had a conversation with a mentor a CEO
of a pretty prominent media company and
he had told me in this conversation wow
that's an interesting idea you should
write about it and it gets back to
beginning in conversation bouncing ideas
off of other people and if I can look at
others and see the surprise on their
face or quite frankly more boredom the
more often the boredom on their face
then I can do more of what's surprising
and less of what bores people so I wrote
up this article put in my email
newsletter got great feedback from
people they a couple emails that said it
was their favorite Monday musings email
ever and then I turned it into an
article and now your friend is asking us
about it here and one thing that I
really want to do and I think this is
going to be a project for the next six
to nine months and I haven't told anyone
about this publicly but this is sort of
a a platform that I want to start
because I think that the never ending
now is problematic and it's not
problematic because we shouldn't be
consuming present information the issue
is that the we don't have people
building to bring up books and articles
that are a bit older if you ever if
someone ever sends you an older article
something from let's say before 2011 you
know it's gonna be good
no doubt about it and so for me if
someone sends me an article I place
disproportionate weight on how long that
article is if it's two days old and
somebody's like hey you should read this
I know that that is a kind of impulsive
share yeah but if it's 20 years old
there's just like you mentioned a kind
of Linde effect and the fact that it's
stuck is stuck with us to this time
means that it's gonna be
disproportionately good so now I'm gonna
say this and now I have to do it because
it's public what I want to do is kind of
create a database of ten twenty thousand
different articles and then what you can
do is you can go in search by keyword
and there'll be mostly old articles from
the lasts say 50 years and then you can
get in there none of them are gonna be
sensitive to time they're just gonna be
interesting ideas and then what we'll
get is look what one thing that is true
about the Internet is it has a kind of
perfect memory so we there there's no
bigger cost to pulling back old
information like if I was going to the
library if I needed a book from say 1970
I need to go probably to the library or
go buy it on Amazon not true with the
internet so what I'm gonna do is build a
database of thousands of articles people
are gonna be able to search and through
this platform we'll get out of the never
ending now and
I'll just do it because I believe so
strongly in the power of the rule of the
written word but also I see and sense an
opportunity where if we can design our
platforms differently we can increase
the quality of knowledge consumption and
escape the never ending now I get that
that was one of the reasons why I was
super drawn to medium when I first
learned about it that it was the first
ever I guess intellectually stimulating
platform that was delivering results to
me based on their either effectiveness
or popularity rather than irrelevance
like Google Google delivers its search
results on relevance I don't want what
is most relevant to my search result
like what I'm after is what's best for
it but because anything could be super
super 100% relevant but actually deliver
the message in a way that no one else
found interesting like and especially
with the way that people can manipulate
SEO tags and all the meditator and
headers and stuff like that like a
medium for me was a real change with
regards to the way that they deliver a
lot of that content because when you're
searching for things you can search for
them based on other people's ratings
which crowd sources the evolution of
what gets to the top absolutely so I
think that there's a couple more things
going on there and and and you bring up
a really good point on the difference
between Google and medium and I think
medium is pretty good but not
exceptional I always could never yeah
yeah I almost never read medium as a
destination site so something about it
then still isn't good enough
what do you think of it but yeah yeah
I'll get into that so let me just start
with Google so the thing that Google is
structured for is answering questions so
Google the best results on Google and
look you can game the algorithm but the
Google SEO algorithm is pretty damn good
but it's for answering questions so what
you find is good simple information but
I don't seem to find
very interesting things on Google and I
rarely seem to come across like a
perspective that is like ha I've never
thought of it like that before Google is
much more like ok now I know what I need
to do or I know where I need to go I
know how to make that cake I know how to
take the cap off my car etc etc exactly
exactly where as I subscribe to a
newsletter highly recommend an email
newsletter called the browser $40 a year
are worth every penny and more and they
send 5 interesting articles a day all of
which make my head turn to the side and
kind of surprised me a bit and they
offer new perspectives that I'd never
heard of so yesterday on the flight I
read about the benefits of arranged
marriages and from a woman in India
who's the daughter of two people who had
had an arranged marriage and she was
talking about all the great things that
came out of arranged marriages and so
I'm Rita I'm like I've never thought of
that before I would have never stumbled
on this that wasn't even what I'm
looking for but I'm really glad I found
this Google doesn't do that
ok so medium kind of tried to do
something like that what medium tried to
do was create a hub for people who
didn't have personal web sites to lower
the cost of sharing articles online and
I think that if I'm being honest with
you I think medium was better a couple
years ago I mean missed the beam has
been kind of watered down by a lot of
self-help stuff and has still been very
susceptible to what's popular and what
gets claps and with that said there's a
lot don't get me wrong there's a lot of
amazing writing on medium just stellar
writing on medium but I'm not sure that
the homepage does a great job of
surfacing that writing and we need to
get better about that as a society but
really just personally I there isn't a
platform where I can just go on the
platform and if this
map of a finger find an interesting
article that is also personalized I get
that completely I mean that's I guess
that's the goal for medium that's what
it could be or should be but yeah it
would be it would be lovely
and one thing that I wanted to touch on
before we finished was talking about so
we've spoken about you spending some
time with some influences and these guys
kind of furiously being on their phones
also the value of writing we've spoken
about how it's both useful for yourself
to be forced to articulate your ideas
and also for other people to then give
you feedback so that they iterate over
time and you kind of evolve your own
consciousness as a back and forth with
other people one of the things I've been
thinking about a lot recently is the
success of people on social media
especially the ones who have the biggest
audiences let's use Instagram and
Twitter as an example the guys who get
to the real real top yeah being
encouraged to use their platform in a
way like this like to use it to write
things which are deep and difficult and
meaningful and grapple with difficult
ideas
I appreciate that when you have half of
the internet like it like Kim
Kardashian's not going to begin to
grapple with the finer points of why
brexit should I shouldn't happen like
that's not her bag but I do sometimes
feel like as as I see and I've seen this
trajectory of some of my buddies as well
that have made it to social media
superstardom yeah they almost it almost
feels like the ideas as you get to the
top of the tree and obviously these are
the ones that are proliferate into the
most because at the top you go further
they almost get more watered out they're
more beige they're more vanilla they're
they're less interesting and they follow
the same kind of the same model because
that's the model that they know is
effective and to change anything would
be a real risk it would be lovely to see
some guys who guys and girls we make it
to the top of the tree and then begin to
go right and now have this platform
let's see what difficult things I can
grapple with let's see I have half a
million 1 million 2 million people that
follow me imagine how good and how
quickly my ideas could iterate and how
fast they devolve if I used all of those
people's feedbacks oh absolute
but I mean I wouldn't be too down on
this there are look there I wish there
were a hundred a thousand times more but
there are some unbelievable content
creators out there who are not trying to
water down at all I mean in the podcast
realm you have Patrick o Shaughnessy who
runs the invest like the best podcast
Patrick does a phenomenal job
interviewing and the level at which he
maintains that podcast I mean that
podcast has had some of the best
interviews I've ever heard and he still
keeps raising the bar I mean it's wildly
impressive what he's achieved there
Tyler Cowen who funds me through his
emergent ventures grant he writes at
marginal revolution every day and I'm
wowed with his production of
high-quality content the quality of his
conversations with Tyler interview
series you have people like Eric
Weinstein who who come up with some just
ridiculously and something ideas he's on
another check out check out the embedded
growth obligation an idea I'll send it
to you you can throw out the show notes
or something but listeners Google an
embedded growth obligation fascinating
idea and whether he's right or wrong the
consistency in which he makes me think
differently and all of those people do
is is impressive and look there's there
are certain incentives online for people
to water down the quality of their
content but there's also so many people
and who are going the opposite route and
I am on a mission and I'm stopping it
nothing to teach thousands of people to
write online to improve their ideas and
to bathe in the reverie of intellectual
ideas that make this life so interesting
that's awesome um I think moving forward
it it does feel to me like in the last
five years we have turned a little bit
of a corner in a really good way the
proliferation of the intellectual dark
dark weapon and
hunger for these sort of experiences I
went to go and see Jordan Peterson live
in Manchester I did - I did - in New
York and I'm like he's a psychology nerd
like a Canadian psychology nerd talking
about life on stage I wonder how many
people would have been there like even
five years ago whether he would have got
that proliferation of ideas through the
internet and it just seems like such an
it seems like something that shouldn't
be happening but there obviously is this
massive massive audience that's hungry
for these ideas people at ben shapiro
and sam harris eric and brett weinstein
like you know these guys are delivering
content which isn't immediately
gratifying at least on the surface of it
if you were to look at what what people
usually consider to be gratifying and
yet they're the some of the most engaged
in some of the most loyal readerships
and fan bases on the internet yeah yeah
absolutely I mean that's a whole that
that's a whole other conversation about
Jordan Peterson I have good friends who
despise the guy and good friends who
love the guy and there's actually I'm
good arguments on either side but yes I
think that your point about how much
people want interesting ideas that's
being underestimated and to get back to
some of the things I'm working on I
recently wrote an essay called what the
hell is going on trying to explain we
were Thanksgiving dinner we're having a
conversation about what was happening in
society and I was hearing my my aunt and
and my uncle speak and I was just like
you guys are totally wrong just
absolutely wrong you're missing some
critical components of what's happening
right now and I wrote an essay trying to
work through those ideas and basically
the world of course is changing and this
shift from information scarcity to
information abundance and the paradox
the weird way in which abundance can
sometimes be harder to deal with than
scarcity is fascinating and something
that I really want to keep exploring but
look I wouldn't get to down because I'm
gonna make sure that uh that there's
thousands of really high-quality
thinkers out there cuz I have a course
that's ready to ready to really raise
them and to teach them and to show them
the way I don't do it man I don't do it
so for the listeners at home that are
interested in the course and to find
more out about yourself where is best to
find you online yeah
Perl comm is my website P ER e ll
dot-com go to the start here page and
you'll find something good there you can
find me on twitter at david underscore
Perel and of course I have the North
Star podcast Chris it was great talking
to you and I hope that we get a chance
to meet in person
yeah me too month thank you very much
have a good day
[Music]
you